I wanna start by saying congrats on the
movie all of you guys did such great
work it is I knew a lot about Queen but
I really didn't know a lot about Paul
until I saw the movie for the first time
or with the footage how much did you
know about Paul and Freddy's
relationship prior to you know getting
involved I knew nothing until I read the
script and then I actually went for a
different character originally I was
auditioning for Jim Holton who was
Freddy's partner until he passed away
and it was only when I read the script
as like that that's a fascinating person
in Paul printer but it kind of didn't
think about it too much until they then
got off the roll and started doing the
research I didn't have any idea that
there was this person who had such a
strong hold of a Freddy's life for a
certain period of time and it was it was
fascinating as an actor to try and
figure out what what drove him on to do
those things after seeing the movie I
went and researched a little bit and saw
there's footage out there of the two of
them at like parties and he's whispering
in his ear and I'm like oh Sh the movie
totally gets this yeah so how much did
you how much footage is there of their
relationship and what did you take away
from everything you saw I think very
much what you've seen is pretty much all
that's out there it's only really
limited there isn't a loss and it tends
to be in documentaries about Freddy's
life and about Queen that you get these
little snippets and chances to see who
this person was and what they got
managed to capture in the movie which is
always great is he always tended to be
right on the shoulder he always tended
to be around Freddy that's what what I
tried to get in the movie was I
definitely watch whatever was being
rehearsed and I was like where would he
be
and sure enough suddenly he does you
know you'd find yourself just over
shoulder always listening always trying
to control the situation and that's
certainly when you speak to the divine
you speak to Brian or Roger he was
someone who loved having that control
and would always be around to make sure
that he heard something or overheard and
could use that against other people but
I think he was also someone who got into
a position of power and started to use
it in a way that maybe he didn't
originally intend to I was curious about
if you had spoken to Roger and Brian
and a prior to filming or during filming
and what they told you about him that
maybe surprised you or was it what was
in that script funny actually Brian only
came up to me I think was my last day of
filming and he came up and said I know
haven't said much to you but you look so
like the guy that I find it kind of hard
to come up until you were finished but
he said that having seen the movie and
seeing what I was doing he said he was
he was a character he was tricky and
they have a lot of resentment for him
for the fact that he kind of shut down a
lot of opportunities for them in America
because people weren't ringing Queen
their ring and Freddy and Paul was
answering the phone so he was
controlling that so there's a lot of
resentment there I'm glad that they feel
that I've captured him correctly sure
but um so yeah
Rami does such a phenomenal job as
Freddy it is like a literal
transformation when did you first see
him as Freddy was it on set with Anna
her soul who's on set
they were doing Live Aid which they shot
in the first week and I came round just
to meet all the band and he was standing
there he was in all the gear but he was
he wasn't doing the voice just yet
because he wasn't onstage but he was
there and he was like hey man good to
see you and it was just incredible to
watch that transformation every day as
well and then to see the physicality cuz
I was just one just seeing him in
appearance was one thing and
mind-blowing I know when he got on stage
and suddenly he just became him in every
every mannerism every move every dance
move and then he started to speak and
you're like that's this is you knew it
was something special
completely there's a great scene with
you and him with the when he's doing
love on my life oh yeah at the piano
yeah
can you talk a little bit about filming
that scene yeah there's a third of the
scene between Paul and Freddy where Paul
makes an advance on him it's at this
point Freddy hasn't said he was gay or
he probably wasn't sure himself and Paul
goes to kiss him and then he says we
work together that's as far as it'll go
and that was a nod to the fact that
there are many stories when you read all
the books that whether they had a
relationship or not I'm gonna switch
gears a little bit and say that I am I
never thought of Downton Abbey movie was
gonna happen it was one of those things
where like they talk about it but I'm
like no way yeah never gonna happen
imagine Maggie going I'm sorry what but
then they're like I'm also curious cuz
like it sounds like they're bringing a
whole bunch of people back I'm very
confused by this thing so what is the
Downton Abbey movie if you don't write
down Stevens
putting out an Instagram saying I can't
wait to go back to work he did that and
that wasn't fair because there's no dead
people coming back the ghosts experience
yeah it's not here or coming up next
Halloween you know yeah
zombie zombie hobby so it's it's very
much it's a continuation of their lives
but on a much more epic scale something
occurs within the family and other
outside sources that makes it makes it
go from a TV show into a movie see what
I'm curious about is and maybe you can
answer this a lot of people have heard
of Downton Abbey yeah but maybe haven't
seen it yeah so how does the movie sort
of acknowledge will you have to have
seen the show or do you think the movie
is sort of like you don't need to know
anything you could come and join the
family at the start of this movie and it
wouldn't make a difference but that's
what Julian's gift us like sure he has
the ability to do that and if you
haven't known those characters ever
within five minutes of movie you'll know
all of them
so have you filmed it or you film a film
and right now is filming yesterday from
midnight last night yeah really when do
you wrap on that thing I wrap on Tuesday
and then I get straight into train and
get down and get changed to go to the
premiere of this Wow so that's gonna be
a big day that's gonna be a big day yeah
and I really hope all the elements fall
together I was gonna say and leads me my
last thing this is world premiering at
Wembley Stadium yeah which is effing
crazy yeah and perfect yeah
are you already just like I cannot
believe we're doing this and what do you
expect from the experience because I
think the crowd might sing along I think
there definitely will be audience
participation
I couldn't believe when I heard that
there was opening there I was just so
excited to get this I've been part of
this movie and having loved their music
since I was a kid my parents used to
play it just the opportunity to go to
this thing would have been exciting let
alone be in it so I think there's
definitely gonna be crying participation
I hope that doesn't involve me going
onstage at the end of it obviously just
say hi and getting booed by 6,000 people
sure my life my last
question there's always I could have
watched a five hour movie of this yeah I
mean I was hook line & sinker into it um
were there any deleted scenes that you
were part of that didn't make the
finished film yeah and this kind of two
really interesting moments there's one
of them the whole Meatpacking District
when you went to mineshaft which is part
of now another one bites the dust
that used to be separation and then what
used to happen after when they came out
of that Club was really interesting but
unfortunately that's made the cutting
room floor I'm very curious thank you so
much and congratulations
you